So you got me, you got AI. You're good. Yeah, that's all we, that's all we need. That's all we need. And you talking about AI. That's the third pillar right there. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 251, recorded on August 21, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview, Sean.
既然你有了我，又有了AI，那你就没问题了。没错，这就是我们所需要的。这就是我们所需要的。你提到的AI，那正是第三大支柱。欢迎收听ADSP播客第251期，录制于2025年8月21日。我是Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起采访Sean。
Parenthood, this is part four of a four-part conversation. You heard part three last week. We're doing part four this week, and then you'll hear the first two parts in the next two episodes. In this episode, we chat with Sean about his upcoming keynote talk at C++ Under the Sea. You are going to be keynoting in T-minus a month. I don't think they've announced the other speakers yet. No, they have not. They have not.
关于为人父母，这是四集系列对话的第四部分。你们上周听了第三部分。我们这周做第四部分，接下来的两集你们会听到前两部分。在这一集中，我们和Sean聊了他即将在“C++ Under the Sea”大会上的主题演讲。你还有一个多月就要做主题演讲了。我想他们还没宣布其他演讲者吧？是的，还没有。确实没有。
So tell us briefly what you'll be chatting about. And I think the dates are like October 9th and 10th. So if folks are in Europe or close or are willing to fly to the Netherlands, you can go see Sean's talk. This is current Connor while he is editing this episode, which we recorded on August 21st. And since we recorded, Bryce and I both had our talks accepted to C++ under the C. So not only can you go and see Sean and get to chat with him at C++ Under the Sea, Bryce and I will also be there. So if you're not going to be near or close to Copenhagen or in Norway for NDC Techtown,
那么简单告诉我们你要聊些什么。我想日期大概是10月9日和10日。所以如果大家在欧洲附近，或者愿意飞到荷兰，可以去看看Sean的演讲。这是Connor在剪辑这一集时的实时旁白，我们是在8月21日录制的。自录制以来，我和Bryce的演讲都被“C++ Under the Sea”大会接收了。所以不仅可以去现场看Sean并与他交流，我和Bryce也会在那里。所以如果你不在哥本哈根附近，或者不去挪威参加NDC Techtown，
we will also be in Breda Netherlands on October 9th and 10th. Back to Sean. But yeah, what are you going to be talking about? I'm going to repeat the talk that I just gave it at C++ now, which is titled, Are We There Yet? and the title comes from a talk I gave at the very first it was a keynote at the very first boost con pre C++ now and there's an online recording of it because I also gave it at Google as a Google tech talk in I don't know what year it was so I would have to look it up 2007 something like that
我们也会在10月9日和10日出现在荷兰布雷达。回到Sean的话题。那么，你要讲什么呢？我打算重复我在C++ Now大会上刚做过的演讲，题目是《我们到了吗？》（Are We There Yet?）。这个标题源于我在第一届BoostCon（C++ Now的前身）上做的主题演讲。网上有录音，因为我后来在谷歌也做过一次技术分享，具体是哪一年我得查查，大概是2007年左右。
and that that talk was titled a possible future of software development and basically what laid out at the time was that there was a huge reduction possible if we moved to generic programming, kind of stepping off style generic programming, and we start writing code in terms of algebraic structures so that it can be commonly used, and that gets rid of a lot of the write and rewrite and rewrite and rewrite, the same implementation of an algorithm. It actually leads to code reuse, where objectorian programming had that promise but it was never fulfilled and then started to look at where do we go from here and the idea of where we go from here is what I refer to as as declarative forms this notion of you should be able to to state your intent around how a program is is constructed right so
那次演讲的题目是《软件开发的可能未来》。当时我提出的核心观点是，如果我们转向泛型编程——那种类似Stepanov风格的泛型编程，并开始用代数结构来编写代码，那么代码量将会有巨大的缩减，从而实现通用性。这消除了大量重复编写相同算法实现的工作。它实际上实现了代码复用，而面向对象编程虽然曾许下这个承诺，却从未真正兑现。然后我开始探讨我们该何去何从，我所指的未来方向是“声明式形式”，即你应该能够陈述你对程序构建方式的意图，对吧？
basically you define things structurally and the computer figures out what the right data structures and algorithms are to use to use to realize that And I showed a demo at the time of property models and a UI layout library that I had at the time. I think the property model work is still somewhat unique in the industry. I've published a number of papers on it with Yanko Yardv. So those are all linked on my website. Layout libraries at the time, you know, it was just known as Eve, had quite a unique set of capabilities. I think less so now.
基本上，你从结构上定义事物，然后计算机找出合适的底层数据结构和算法来实现它。当时我演示了属性模型（property models）和一个我当时拥有的UI布局库。我认为属性模型的工作在业内至今仍有些独特。我和Yanko Yardv发表过几篇相关论文，这些都链接在我的网站上。当时的布局库，也就是大家熟知的Eve，拥有一套相当独特的功能。我想现在没那么独特了。
There's a couple of unique capabilities it has. it can do cross hierarchy alignment easily where other layout engines don't. But that was kind of a take on it. And so this talk kind of revisits, so revisits that. How far is generic programming come in the last 20 years? The answer is a lot. Nobody knew what it was 20 years ago, and now it's a significant part of all the major languages.
它确实还有一些独特的功能，比如可以轻松实现跨层级对齐，这是其他布局引擎做不到的。但这只是我当时的一种尝试。所以这次演讲算是对那次的回顾。过去20年泛型编程发展到什么程度了？答案是进步巨大。20年前没人知道它是什么，而现在它已成为所有主流语言的重要组成部分。
It is amazing to think about that just 20 years ago how different the software industry was in that way because it's something that we take that Connor and I think take for granted because we sort of grew up in that environment. Yeah, yeah, I think there are still things that the industry gets wrong about generic programming, so I'll touch on some of those. And then this notion of how do we get to declarative forms, right? At one point, this idea, it's not unique to me, was referred to as like fourth generation
想到20年前软件行业在这一方面是多么不同，真是令人惊叹，因为这对于我和Connor来说是理所当然的，因为我们是在那种环境下成长起来的。是的，是的，我认为行业对泛型编程仍然存在一些误解，所以我也会谈到其中的一些。然后是关于我们如何实现声明式形式的构想，对吧？曾经，这个想法——并非我独创——被称为第四代语言，而Prolog算是其中的典型代表。我认为这个想法是对的，但所有这些系统都因各种原因失败了。所以让我们看看这种策略过去失败的原因，看看我们能否再次尝试，或许换个方向？你认为像那样的声明式语言因为AI的出现而变得更重要了吗？
languages and prologue kind of being the canonical example. And I think the idea was right, but all of these systems have failed for a number of reasons. And so let's look at kind of the reasons why this tact has failed in the past. And can we take another stab at it and maybe go in a different direction? Do you think that declarative languages like that are more relevant these days because of AI? I think potentially they are. One of the things that I'm looking at in my current work is how do I expose the structure directly to the AI? Another group at Adobe has been doing work on a similar area.
我认为有可能。我目前工作的一个方向是如何将结构直接暴露给AI。Adobe的另一个团队也在类似领域进行研究。
And that gets really interesting. It means that you can have your AI build features that weren't there under the hood, right? They can play with the Lego blocks, if you will, more at a user level than at a raw coding level. Wasn't Prolog like originally developed by an AI lab back in the 70s? You know, I do not know that. I would have to look that up. Certainly it's got early AI. It was created around 1972 by some guy from the University of France in their artificial intelligence group.
这变得非常有趣。这意味着你可以让AI构建底层原本不存在的功能，对吧？它们可以像玩乐高积木一样，在用户层面而不是原始编码层面进行操作。Prolog不是最初由70年代的一个AI实验室开发的吗？你知道，我不知道这一点。我得查查。当然，它确实有早期的AI背景。它大约是在1972年由法国大学人工智能小组的某个人创建的。
Yeah. So, yeah, so I think these things connect well to AI, and I think potentially solve a lot of the problems of AI. And, you know, what my goal is is to say that, you know, you want to build a set of domain-specific languages as well that all interoperate, as well as the infrastructure to define new languages within that family. And each of the languages, the goal should be to solve a particular class of problems well and to be as provable as possible. And so, like, one of the attributes of the layout system that I did, it's a constraint-based system, but you can neither over-constraint or under-constraint it,
是的。所以，我认为这些东西与AI联系紧密，并且可能解决AI的许多问题。你知道，我的目标是说，你需要构建一套能够互操作的领域特定语言，以及定义该系列内新语言的基础设施。每种语言的目标都应该是很好地解决特定类别的难题，并尽可能做到可证明。比如，我做的布局系统的一个属性是，它是一个基于约束的系统，但你既不会过度约束也不会约束不足，
any layout that you describe, it will give a layout. And I tried to do the same with property models and fell a little bit short. There is a model checker where if you run the model checker and it succeeds, then you know that there's a solution for any set of values that you feed into the system. The problem is 20 years ago at the time, I did kind of a back-of-the-emphalo proof of the complexity of the model checker and said, It looks like it's N-Log N-ish, something like that. I recently pulled up those notes and found several mistakes,
你描述的任何布局，它都能给出一个结果。我试图在属性模型上也这样做，但稍微差了一点。有一个模型检查器，如果运行它并成功，你就知道你输入系统的任何一组值都有解决方案。问题是20年前，我凭直觉对模型检查器的复杂度做了一个粗略证明，说它看起来像是N-Log N之类的。我最近翻出那些笔记，发现有几个错误，
and it's like, no, it's N-Choose-M-M-ish, which is a whole different. So it's probably only reasonable to fully model-check things at a small scale. So I'm looking at how do you build a system that can do a better job at model-checking above that? Yeah, you know, I think if you, you know, when you write code, if you've ever had the sense of, of, I'm writing kind of the same thing again, right? Right. I'm solving a similar problem that falls into a family of problems I've had before. Then this notion of how do you back up and how do you describe that class of problems and how do you get to the point where you can solve it once gets interesting. So that's the direction of the talk. I'm hoping to get a demo together
实际上它是N选M的复杂度，这完全是另一回事。所以可能只在小规模下进行完全模型检查才合理。所以我正在研究如何构建一个能在该规模之上更好地进行模型检查的系统。是的，你知道，我认为当你写代码时，如果你曾经有过“我好像又在写同样的东西”的感觉，对吧？没错。我正在解决一个类似的问题，它属于我以前遇到过的一类问题。那么如何退后一步，如何描述那类问题，以及如何达到可以一次性解决它的地步，这就变得很有趣了。这就是演讲的方向。我希望能整理出一个演示，
of my new work right now I could show a bunch of rust code but it's not wait wait to be clear your plan for your keynote at the C++ post conference is to show a bunch of rest code I mean I'm not saying that's inappropriate I just want to be clear
关于我的新工作。现在我可以展示一堆Rust代码，但它不是……等等，等等，说清楚点，你计划在C++大会的主题演讲中展示一堆Rust代码？我的意思是，我不是说这不合适，我只是想确认一下。
I plan is hopefully to show a demo of a small slice of a functioning system if I were to you know the closest I could give right now is be like oh look at all this rust code I've written and if I run it on the command line that puts out these numbers, which are somewhat interesting to me. So if I'm only at that point still, I won't give a demo.
我的计划是希望能展示一个功能系统的一小部分演示。如果我现在能给出的最接近的东西就是“哦，看我写的所有这些Rust代码，如果我在命令行运行它，它会输出这些数字”，这对我来说有点意思。所以如果我还是只到那个阶段，我就不会做演示了。
It wouldn't be interesting. I could give a demo at a Rust conference and talk about the structure of the code, and that might be interesting, but not as it was interesting. I have learned that running concurrently with CPP under the sea, there is a big AI conference in Amsterdam. I can't remember the name. World, AI, Summit, Amsterdam, maybe is the...
那不会很有趣。我可以在Rust大会上做演示并谈论代码结构，那可能很有趣，但在这里不行。我了解到，在C++ Under the Sea大会同期，阿姆斯特丹有一个大型AI会议。我不记得名字了。可能是“世界AI峰会，阿姆斯特丹”……
Interesting name. Yes, it's on the 8th and the 9th. So, yeah, there's some potential crossover there. And then, you know, for your European listeners, before C++, under the sea, Sergei Platonov
名字很有趣。是的，是在8号和9号。所以，是的，那里有一些潜在的交叉点。然后，你知道，对于你们的欧洲听众，在C++ Under the Sea之前，Sergei Platonov
has invited me to do a meetup and so I will do probably the same talk in person in a meetup in Zurich a stop by Zurich on my way to on my way to the Netherlands for people who don't know Sergey
邀请我去做一个聚会，所以我可能会在去荷兰的路上顺道在苏黎世做一个同样的线下演讲。对于不知道Sergei的人，
he's the person who started C++ Russia and when the Russian Ukraine war broke out his wife is Ukraine and he fled the country and now was in Zurich, which was very sad. The day before the war broke out,
他是创办C++ Russia的人。当俄乌战争爆发时，他的妻子是乌克兰人，他逃离了那个国家，现在在苏黎世，这非常令人难过。战争爆发的前一天，
he sent me an invite to speak at C++ Russia again. That was a good conference. It's a shame. Yes. The reason, though, I was saying that is we had such a blast at C++ on sea. I want to say it was 2023 at this point, because I... Yeah.
他给我发了邀请，让我再次在C++ Russia演讲。那是个很好的会议。真可惜。是的。我之所以这么说，是因为我们在C++ on Sea玩得太开心了。我想那应该是2023年，因为我……是的。
Was it 2023? I think it must have been, yeah. It was either, it definitely wasn't this year. So it was either 24 or 23. But anyways, it was a blast recording in person, you know, during the dinner, post-dinner. And if it's not, it's C++ under the C, we will try to have to make that happen in person again. Because as fun as it, I mean, this was amazing, to be honest. I don't know how you've managed to bundle so many, like,
是2023年吗？我想一定是。肯定不是今年。所以要么是24年要么是23年。但无论如何，在晚餐期间、晚餐后进行面对面录制真是太棒了。如果不是在C++ Under the Sea，我们也会尽量再次实现面对面录制。因为说实话，这太棒了。我不知道你是怎么把这么多……
internet happy topics we've got rest versus c plus plus we've got AI and we've got like the dystopic or utopic future that lays ahead for us should people be worried or not so this is just going to be banger after banger but yeah as fun as this was we're we will have to try to do this again in person at some point whether at a conference or I'm sure Bryce and I will be in Santa Clara at some point at the same time the problem is we usually go a different because we're on different teams. But maybe next year at GTC, if you're going to be there and I'm going to be there.
我们聊了互联网热门话题，Rust对决C++，我们聊了AI，还有摆在我们面前的反乌托邦或乌托邦式的未来，人们是否应该担心等等。所以这绝对会是一场接一场的精彩内容。但正如这次一样有趣，我们以后还是得找机会面对面录制，无论是在会议上，还是我相信Bryce和我也总会在某个时候同时出现在圣克拉拉。问题是我们通常因为在不同团队而错开时间。但也许明年在GTC，如果你会在那里，我也会在那里。
You live in the air, Sean. Yeah, I know Bryce was like at the most recent GTC. I've actually been to California. After the fact, I'm like, I'm a block away. Yeah, I've actually been to California like six times since then, but I've just, it's been, the travel's been so crazy this year that it's all work. I haven't had, I haven't had any spare time.
你住在飞机上，Sean。是的，我知道Bryce参加了最近的GTC。实际上我事后才去过加州，当时我就在隔壁街区。是的，自那以后我其实去过加州六次了，但今年的行程太疯狂了，全是工作。我一点空闲时间都没有。
Yeah. But, but yeah, I'm sure we'll, I mean, I suspect we'll both be at GTC this year, Connor, hopefully. Hopefully. I mean, GTC has become like, you know, I don't know. What's the comparison of like some Epcot Center Disneyland, or not even Disneyland, Disney World? Like, they rent out half a San Jose. I couldn't even get into the keynote last year. I was, I was just like, oh, yeah, I'll just show up like a couple minutes beforehand.
是的。但，但确实，我相信我们会……我的意思是，我猜我们今年都会参加GTC，Connor，希望如此。希望如此。我的意思是，GTC已经变得像……我不知道。该怎么比喻，像艾普科特中心（Epcot Center）还是迪士尼乐园，甚至不是迪士尼乐园，是迪士尼世界？他们租下了半个圣何塞。去年我甚至没能进入主题演讲现场。我当时就想，哦，是的，我提前几分钟到就行了。
there was like a line line around the block. It was so, I'll tell one last story. Then we'll be done. Back in 2017, when I was still at Berkeley Lab, I was thinking about coming to invidia. And I always like to, so in the Jewish religion, if you want to convert to Judaism, it's supposed to not be easy to convert. And the rabbi is supposed to tell you no the first two times.
结果排队排到了街区外。太……我讲最后一个故事，然后我们就结束。回到2017年，我还在伯克利实验室时，我正考虑加入NVIDIA。我总是喜欢……在犹太教中，如果你想皈依犹太教，这并不容易。拉比前两次应该拒绝你。
And then if you come back and you come back the third time, and you say, yeah, I want to convert. Then he's like, all right, all right, you can convert. And so when I was in this process looking for a new job, I approached Olivier, my old mentor at NVIDIA. And the first time he was like, oh, I'm not sure if you'd like it here, coming from academia. And the second time is like, oh, I'm not sure where we'd put you.
然后如果你第三次回来，说“是的，我想皈依”，他才会说“好吧，好吧，你可以皈依”。所以当我在寻找新工作时，我联系了我在NVIDIA的老导师Olivier。第一次他说：“哦，我不确定你是否会喜欢这里，毕竟你来自学术界。”第二次他说：“哦，我不确定我们该把你放在哪里。”
And then, like, eventually I went and I asked him the third time. But in between the second and the third time, because I was sort of entranced to come to a, and Vidia by Olivier, Michael, and Jared, because they were, I just, they were the people, they were a small delegation in the C++ committee compared to Google or Microsoft, but they seemed to get so much more stuff done and be so sharp, and Olivier just loved talking passionately about the chip he was designing and why GPUs were superior to CPUs for compute workloads. And I was very convinced coming from the CPUs, Cindy world.
然后，最终我第三次去问他。但在第二次和第三次之间，因为我被Olivier、Michael和Jared吸引想去NVIDIA，因为他们……他们是C++委员会中相对于谷歌或微软的一小群代表，但他们似乎完成了更多工作，而且非常敏锐。Olivier总是充满激情地谈论他设计的芯片，以及为什么GPU在计算工作负载上优于CPU。我当时来自CPU和SIMD世界，对此深信不疑。
I bought what he was selling me. And he kept hinting that they were going to launch a very cool chip at GTC. And so I decided I was going to go down for GTC 2017 for the keynote day. So like I woke up at like 6 a.m. And I drove down from Berkeley to Santa Clara. And this was when it was still in the convention center before it had to go to the stadium. And I guess I would. still Bryce even then because I get I get to the entrance and I'm letting people in and I see a line
我被他说服了。他一直暗示他们将在GTC上发布一款非常酷的芯片。所以我决定去参加GTC 2017的主题演讲日。我早上6点起床，从伯克利开车到圣克拉拉。那时会议还在会议中心，还没搬到体育场。我想即使那时我也认识Bryce，因为我到了入口处，看到人们在排队，
for like a press and I'm just like what the heck I'll just go in the press line and they didn't check any IDs or anything and they took everybody in the press lines got to go up to like the front row and so I was in the front row of the GTC 2017 keynote when Jensen launched Volta launched TensorFlows like that that was like a huge monument. GTC, and that was the launch of VALTA, which was like a paradigm shift in GPUs for us. And I was just there in the first row, live tweeting, and it sort of blew up my Twitter, because I was able to get all these good pictures because everybody else was at least 10 rows behind because they had all these spots reserved for the press people.
排的是媒体通道，我就想，管他呢，我就去媒体通道排队。他们没查任何证件，就把媒体通道的所有人都放进去了。我们直接坐到了前排。所以当Jensen发布Volta和TensorFlow时，我就在GTC 2017主题演讲的第一排，那是一个巨大的里程碑。GTC，那是Volta的发布，对我们来说是GPU的范式转移。我就在那里第一排直播发推，我的Twitter账号因此火了，因为我拍到了所有这些好照片，而其他人至少在10排之后，因为那些位置都留给了媒体人员。
And then I went to go see Olivier's talk, and I was convinced I was sold I wanted to go to Nvidia after that, and I went home after. I can't wait to the version of this story, you know, in the next 10 years where, like, Bryce ends up behind bars because he was over-entitled and just like, oh, no, I'm supposed to, hey, hey, hey, officer, officer. Yeah. Oh, man. I want to note at the end of that story that that was before I was an employee of NVIDIA, so my misspave here was perfectly fine. All right, well, we should have a security incident now to review their preference. protocol. I'm sure
然后我去看Olivier的演讲，我被说服了，我确定我想去NVIDIA，之后我就回家了。我迫不及待想听听这个故事在未来10年的版本，比如Bryce因为过度自信而最终入狱，然后说：“哦，不，我应该……嘿，嘿，警官，警官。”是的。天哪。我想在故事结尾说明一下，那是在我成为NVIDIA员工之前，所以我的这种行为完全没问题。好吧，我们现在应该有一个安全事件来审查他们的协议。我相信
they run a much tighter ship now than they used to. Yeah. Sean, are you still coming out to New York at all? I have not recently. You know, I met up with you guys
他们现在的管理比以前严格多了。是的。Sean，你最近还会来纽约吗？最近没有。你知道，我上次去那里时和你们见过面。
last time I was there. So yeah, it will probably happen at some point. Yeah, my organization is sliding under Titus's. So I'm going to report through Titus too here. pretty soon.
所以是的，可能在某个时候会发生。是的，我的组织正在划归到Titus旗下。所以我很快也要向Titus汇报了。
I forgot Titus was at Adobe. I haven't talked to him in forever. Yeah, we got Titus. We got Hiram. We got all the cool kids here. Is Titus speaking at conferences still? I haven't seen his name pop up recently. I've seen Davids because David was at C++.
我忘了Titus在Adobe了。我好久没和他说话了。是的，我们有Titus，有Hiram，我们这里有所有酷孩子。Titus还在参加会议演讲吗？我最近没看到他的名字出现。我看到过David的，因为David在C++大会上。
I've seen David's name pop up a couple places, but I haven't seen Titus's. Yeah, yeah. No, I haven't seen Titus speaking anywhere recently. Yeah, I think he's been heads down. So he's reluctantly growing his org, and I think it's growing a little bigger, a little faster than he wants. I was going to say, that's good news for the folks that are hoping, you know, for jobs and whatnot. But potentially it's just all internal reorgs and people joining his, what do you call it, binary or what is, what do you call a tree that's not binary, that's just a tree, I guess. Yeah, just a tree.
我看到过David的名字在几个地方出现，但没看到Titus的。是的，是的。不，我最近没看到Titus在任何地方演讲。是的，我想他一直在埋头苦干。他正在勉强扩大他的组织，我想它增长得比他想要的稍微大一点、快一点。我正想说，这对那些希望找工作的人来说是好消息。但可能这只是内部重组，人们加入他的……你叫它什么，二叉树还是什么？你叫那种不是二叉树的树叫什么，我想就是树吧？是的，就是树。
An erie tree. I got to get going because we've got to go to the U.S. Open cool a little bit well plug if you get it in for your listeners I think CareerStadadadadadadcom I do think Adobe still still has some open slots okay yeah there you go if you're
一棵普通的树。我得走了，因为我们得去美国公开赛……好吧，如果你能为你的听众插播一下，我想CareerStadadadadadadcom，我确实认为Adobe还有一些空缺职位，好的，就是这样，如果你是
we will plug it we will plug it a new graduate or not a new graduate and just out looking for a change or looking for something new it sounds like you got a lot of cool people at Adobe, regardless of where you end up, you'll be working with some cool folks. Yeah, yeah, good company and happy here.
我们会插播的，我们会插播的。无论是应届毕业生还是非应届毕业生，只要是在寻找改变或寻找新机会的人，听起来你在Adobe有很多很酷的人，无论你最终在哪里，你都会和一些很酷的人一起工作。是的，是的，好公司，在这里很开心。
All right, thanks so much, Sean. This has been an absolute blast. I must, well, I'll find it in after the fact, in post, and edit in the person. Someone, there was a couple comments that I got on recent episodes. One of them was, it was a photo. This is what the ADSP podcast has been recently, and they took our logo, deleted everything except for the A
好的，非常感谢Sean。这绝对是一次非常愉快的谈话。我必须……好吧，我会在后期制作中找到它，并把面对面的部分剪辑进去。有人在最近的几集里评论了几句。其中一个是照片。这就是ADSP播客最近的样子，他们拿走了我们的Logo，删除了除了A以外的所有东西，
and then added a white eye next to it. And then the other comment I got was like, where is Sean? I mean, it's great that you two are here, but I'm here for the Sean content. And I was like, oh, that's true. We haven't had Sean on in a while. We've got to fix that ASAP. And so now we have done so. But we'll make sure it's sooner, whatever the Delta was, it's sooner than that amount of time until the next time we have you on.
然后旁边加了一个白色的眼睛。另一个评论是“Sean在哪里？”我的意思是，你们两个在这里很好，但我是为了Sean的内容来的。我当时想，哦，那是真的。我们已经很久没请Sean来了。我们必须尽快解决这个问题。所以现在我们做到了。但我们会确保下一次，无论间隔多久，都会比这次的时间短。
So you got me, you got AI. You're good. Yeah, that's all we need. That's all we need. And you talking about AI. That's the third pillar right there. we'll just we'll just train a sean AI model from all the past podcasts no it's not the same it's not although i would if we did that we'd have to get you sean to come and just talk to
所以你有了我，又有了AI。你没问题。是的，这就是我们所需要的。这就是我们所需要的。你提到的AI，那正是第三大支柱。我们只会……我们只会用过去所有的播客训练一个Sean AI模型。不，那不一样，那不一样。虽然如果我们要那样做，我们得让你Sean来，然后只是和
yourself then that would be that would be content worth listening to um a discussion with sean parent and sean parent you make a very good point yeah yeah i mean we're going to be living in a future soon where, especially for the three of us, we just point them at the episodes and say, go create a model. There's actually a company I've heard of called Delphi, where it's literally very similar to the Black Mirror episode where a person's partner passes away and they feed it texts and then emails and it gets better and better, where somehow they train a basically digital replica of you. And then if you're a busy person, you can just go ask the Delphi, go ask Conner's Delphi first or go ask Sean's Delphi. And then,
你自己对话。那将是值得一听的内容。嗯，Sean Parent和Sean Parent的讨论。你提出了一个很好的观点。是的，是的，我的意思是，我们很快就会生活在未来，特别是对于我们三个人来说，我们只需把它们指向这些剧集，然后说“去创建一个模型”。实际上我听说过一家叫Delphi的公司，它字面上非常类似于《黑镜》中一个人伴侣去世后，他们把文本和电子邮件喂给它，它变得越来越好，以至于他们以某种方式训练了一个基本上是你的数字复制品。然后如果你是一个忙碌的人，你可以直接去问Delphi，先去问Connor的Delphi或者去问Sean的Delphi。然后，
And, you know, you can review all your Delphi's responses pretty quick. Oh, that's good, good, good, good, just to make sure it's doing a good job. And so you basically can copy yourself, which is listening to the podcast about that. They were very high on it. And it sounded very creepy. But at the same time, you're like, I guess I would like to have an extra of me if you could get more work done. Or like the questions that you don't like answering, whether that's professionally, socially, in your relationship.
而且，你知道，你可以很快地审查你Delphi的所有回复。哦，那很好，很好，很好，很好，只是为了确保它做得很好。所以你基本上可以复制你自己，这听起来就像播客里说的。他们对此评价很高。这听起来很诡异。但同时，你会想，如果能多做点工作，我确实想要一个额外的我。或者像那些你不喜欢回答的问题，无论是专业上、社交上还是在你的关系中。
You just go talk to my Delphi about that, okay? there are certainly a number of meetings where I wouldn't mind just you know it's like my attendance is required only because politically my face should be there and it's like like just put an avatar for me in there and I'll go write some code yeah we'll see we might be living in that future soon because we can all think of examples of that where yeah whether it's meetings or something okay we'll let you go then Sean thanks so much be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and
你只需去和我的Delphi谈谈那个，好吗？确实有很多会议我不在意……你知道，就像我的出席只是因为政治上我的脸应该在那里，就像“给我在那里放个头像，我去写点代码”。是的，我们走着瞧，我们可能很快就会生活在那个未来，因为我们都能想到那样的例子，无论是会议还是其他什么。好的，那我们就让你走了，Sean，非常感谢。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和
questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号。我们的口号是“混乱中夹杂着信息”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。